[Music]
I miss you so much I miss you too Mama
will you be careful out there
always mommy I'm very happy to be back
home h Huh but things are
different I a piano in my house and I
don't play the
[Music]
piano do you have hallucinations
Mama
yeah astronauts go through things they
don't understand that's when people come
unstuck when I was up there the only
thing I could focus on was getting back
to my daughter I miss you mommy will you
be careful out there Mommy who was that
that was you and me right before the
accident that was not
me
mama where is
she
you I invented a machine we took into
space and I saw something but it seems
like it doesn't want to be
seen people SE things up there and when
they get back they go
crazy this isn't
Madness you need to help
me I need to go back to
her do I seem the same to
you I just don't feel like you my
[Music]
mom